I think that's where like sometimes like
they they'll get into like disagreements
I don't know and the one thing that's
interesting you said on the show how you
were talking about how you should sleep
around as a guy when you're single when
you're single yes you should yeah and I
because I think a lot of times the Chad
counts will come in and be like you know
you shouldn't contribute to the problem
you you kind of seem like a mix a bit uh
well I'm just I'm a realist yeah and
that's like and that's what the red pill
guys are saying it's like well we're
just responding to the women like we
wanted we wanted a girl at a 20 year old
virgin but they don't they don't really
exist I don't I don't believe that's
necessarily true I think that what you
said yesterday struck me as you said you
have to be a little bit more selfish I
agree with that that's the Ein Rand you
know the randian philosophy which is
like if you act in your own
self-interest it's up to everybody else
to act in their own self-interest and at
least the best outcome